I heard this about you as well so you're
ready to find love again you're at that
point in your life right yeah I am still
in the stage of like really enjoying me
so I'm not there but after divorce it
can be hard and after like losing a
relationship that you you know thought
you would spend forever with this person
that can be hard so you're you're back
to like no I'm ready ye yes I mean
listen that seems not all in
Shannon I'm enjoying I'm like you right
now I'm enjoying my time it it's it was
it's been a very hard year for me and it
was a very
devastating uh like you thing to go
through and there were some very
shocking revelations so those are fun
those are fun yeah very fun uh but you
know I I rolled over and I cuddled with
my dog in bed and I had a moment with
like her hair got caught in my mouth and
I went maybe I'm ready for
love maybe I would like a man here
you're like man I still want my dogs um
I cuddle with
she will she has priority over the bed
yeah for for now on like my dogs never
knew my like because we didn't allow
dogs in the bed right you know cuz it
was for fun um that kind of fun um but
like so we the good fun but we didn't
allow that but now that I'm s like now
ever since I've been separated now
divorce my dogs have been like ruling my
bed so I think they would be they would
hate the next person that came in my dog
will hate the next person as well but
don't you find that the like your dog's
my dog the minute that that person was
gone it's almost like they gravitated
Towards the bed in order to make sure
that they were like next to us Henry my
dog Henry was like that like my dog
doesn't she's like I'm here I'm here
you're not alone and she cuddles now
it's the weirdest thing I would cry a
lot as you do when grief happens and my
dog would literally he forces he would
my Henry would come in and force his
like head under my arm and just sit
there with me and I was like is there a
man like this around like I was like
anybody I was like anyway I I love that
you're ready for love ready for love
just you know a Henry version of Love
yeah I like dog love for the moment yeah
I think
too I think too there's a lot to learn
about yourself in a relationship and how
you are in a relationship I I think I
need a little more work on that end of
it I'm I'm a little I'm I just I'm going
to leave it there I think I just I need
a little bit work on me in a
relationship and how to make sure I take
care of myself at the same time as
somebody else to not get lost in the
relationship yeah it's not so much that
I'm like man it's just like maybe I
little work on me but yeah and also like
I love me and um I love spending time
with me I know right it's really great
it feels
[Music]
[Applause]
powerful thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home